こんにちははじめしゃちょーです
[音楽]
ドキドキはい今日はですね性病
検査やってみたいと思います
いや別にそんなあの深い意味はないです
深い意味はないよなんか心当たりがあると
かそういう感じで出すんだったら動画にし
ませんよマジの感じだったらもっとなんか
こそこそやるからねただなんか今結構
ネットとかをニュースでなんか取れないも
のってて
梅毒っていう病気感染症性病なのかなすい
ません僕も知識がないんですけれどもなん
かニュースになったりなんか国とか県庁と
かなんかかなりまあ社会問題になってる
らしくて梅毒がめっちゃ流行ってるらしい
んですよでこれ完全に切り継ぎにくいこと
からなんかその治療の遅れだったり感染
拡大がしやすいらしくて今なんか割と年齢
増えてってるらしくてそういうのとか梅毒
に限らず性病って色々あるんですけれども
ちょっと
僕性病にかかったことがですね
なくてあんのかなわかんない
検査したことないからわかんないんですよ
検査したことないからマジでわかんないん
ですけどおそらくないと思いますだって
検査したことないもんわかんないそんなに
なんか流行ってる流行ってる言われると
怖いし1回ちょっと証明しておきたいなと
思ってちょっと今日は性病検査を実際に
やってみたいと思いますなんか病院とかで
受けたりそういうなんか
検査ができる場所とかもあるんですけれど
も自分で検査できる方法があったんですよ
そういうキットみたいなのが届いて今回
それでちょっと検査してみたいと思います
ただほんとしっかりしててなんかその唾液
とか尿とかなんか採血とかもちゃんとし
なきゃいけなくて
採血採血自分でするの怖ちょっと全く知ら
ないんですけれどもちょっと
初めてということで1回ちょっと僕どう
なってるか調べてみたいと思います
というわけで今回スペシャルゲストの方に
お越しいただいておりますどうぞ
[音楽]
どうも
陰部中央大学教授
筆頭中です
よろしくお願いしますよろしくお願いし
ます感染症とかだったり
詳しいんですか
[音楽]
教師笑っちゃいけないんですかこれ大事
ですから
状況によっては本当治療が遅れると命に
関わることもあるのでそうなんですよね
是非とも僕はですね1人でも多くの人に
こういう検査をもっと気軽に受けれるよっ
ていうことを教えてあげたくてはい今回
こういう動画撮ってるわけなんです
なるほどそういう先生は性病とかも経験は
ノーコメントで
も怖いんですけれども他の病気の検査も
できるということでちょっとまるまると1
セットというか
意識そういう検査ができるキットを
ちょっとやっていきたいと思いますでは
行ってきます
これで性病が検査できるみたいです早速
やっていきましょう誰にでも可能性はあり
ますからそうだよな今回調べられるのは
HIV梅毒正規クラミスは定期連権
取りこぼす感じだのどぐろみちゃん喉
リンキンをやっててくれ当てろ当てろ
真ん中ですねちょっと待って落ち着けまし
た
はいそうですそれが一番まずいです
いきましょう
置くだけもう
そうだよね
やばい
うわあ
出た結構
[音楽]
牛乳やん
これでわかるんだ
[音楽]
はいわかりました
おはようございますというわけで尿検査
取りましたこれで全ての項目が終わったの
でこれを多分これでもその業者に
届ければ結果が帰ってくると思います早速
計算していきたいと思います
[音楽]
ね
はい
これさ横線ってことは大丈夫だってこと
陰性的なやつじゃないですか
はいHIV
陰性です
梅毒
が漢字だ
陰性ですクラミジア
喉のね
陰性です
[音楽]
はいというわけで今回の項目すべて
陰性でした
よかったひとまず
良かったです
梅毒ってそういう行為だけじゃなくて普通
にコップの口移して口つけるじゃんコップ
とかでああいうのでも
映っちゃったりするらしいので俺じゃなく
ても俺の周りの誰かとか後輩とかが
サービスとかが
レッドブル最高やなぁこれ
伸ばしてくださいダメだ伸ばしてください
ダメだ
伸びる
あいつが飲んだやつを貰って俺が飲んだり
して映ることもゼロではないらしいので
あのかなり一言ではないなというか本当に
身近に生きてるしそんな
厚生労働省がもう注意喚起出すぐらいだ
からなんか本当にめっちゃ増えてるらしい
んですよ感染者数が気軽にできますって
いうのちょっと見せたくてちょっとふざけ
ちゃったりしたところはあったんですけど
少女とかがかなり分かりにくいので僕が今
やったみたいに初めてでも全然できました
検査気軽に計算できるよっていうのだけで
もちょっとこの動画で分かってくれたら
いいなと思います
どんだけ流行ってるんだろうねああいう
統計で出た人ってさその
検査とか知ってなった人だけだからまだ世
にバイトにかかっててもまだカウントされ
てない人がめちゃくちゃ多いと思うから
かなり
怖いなと思ってちょっともうまず純粋にね
注意喚起しますとか言ったけど本当なんか
自分が怖くてもう本当に興味本位で今回
検査させて頂きましたね僕専門家じゃない
んですけども梅毒に関しては早期発見で
全然その
治療の方法というかいち早く早期発見して
対処するのがいいって聞いたのでちょっと
マジで普通に怖いなって思いましたいや
怖かったーマジで結果出るまでこれ多分誰
がやっても怖いよ本当にわかんないからね
症状もすごい分かりづらいんですよなんか
実際ちゃんと調べてもらった方が絶対いい
と思うんですけども症状も本当に分かり
づらいらしくてマジでちゃんと陰線で出る
まで僕は本当に怖かったですね相当流行っ
てるということで皆さん是非お気を付け
くださいませ
マジで
結果が来る3日間ぐらい結構ビクビクして
てえっと寝不足でしたすぐ寝ますおやすみ
なさい
[音楽]